[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono cresciuta annusando calici di vino
oggi metto il naso sopra pugni di terra
e annuso il suolo sono Chiara de iulis
pepe e mi occupo di agricoltura così
come la mia famiglia da oltre cinque
generazioni credo che annusare il suolo
mi metta in connessione profonda con la
mia terra credo che mi aiuti a fare
meglio il mio lavoro alcuni pugni di
suolo sono friabili morbidi scuri sanno
di buono sono profumati Quello è il
segnale di un suono in salute altri
pugni invece sono pesanti sono
grigiastri sono compatti Quello è il
segnale di un suolo che non funziona
troppo
anche L'osservazione del suolo è un
esercizio che ogni agricoltore Aguzza e
Affina con il tempo perché tutti
ricerchiamo dei suoli friabili morbidi
Soffici areati fertili
c'è una certa gioia che provo nel
camminare su un suolo morbido vuol dire
che c'è qualcuno che da anni si occupa
della salute di quel suolo
Cerco amo I suoli vivi avresti mai
pensato di chiamare la cosa su cui
camminiamo vivo
Eppure lo è nel suolo Infatti abita una
miriade di esseri viventi che fra di
loro
collaborano proliferano assimilano sono
batteri funghi lieviti nematodi tutti
nell'ordine di milioni e milioni per
ogni grammo di suolo pensate che nel
suolo abita i tre quarti della
biodiversità sulla terra
pensate che enorme ricchezza e una
ricchezza ancora più grande quando
pensiamo che il suolo ospita le radici
le radici delle piante su di esso E
allora qui il gioco si fa ancora più
divertente perché le radici iniziano a
scambiare con il suolo attraverso i
microrganismi vivi i microrganismi
diventano intermediario funzionale fra
radici e suono senza i quali questi due
non potrebbero comunicare
E pensate infatti che le radici non
riuscirebbero ad assorbire i nutrienti
che ci sono nella terra senza i
microrganismi e così come le radici non
riuscirebbero a lasciare quello che
hanno accumulato grazie alla fotosintesi
nel suolo
E allora penso che questo diventa il
sistema
neurologico del pianeta
È qui che risiede l'intelligenza della
terra pensate che una pianta in
difficoltà Riesce a ricevere l'aiuto di
un'altra pianta più in salute grazie a
questa intelligenza
e diventa un intelligenza ancora più
elevata Quando riceve l'aiuto di questo
processo
elegantissimo e magico che è la
fotosintesi
e qui le piante e i microrganismi del
suolo collaborano per sottrarre anidride
carbonica dall'atmosfera e tramite un
lungo processo
assorbono e accumulano anidride
carbonica in complessi resistenti e
stabili nel sottosuolo e li stoccano per
decadi e decadi
allora che il suolo a questo punto
diventa un enorme magazzino di
stoccaggio di anidride carbonica
e allo stesso tempo una delle più
intelligenti tecnologiche tecnologie di
sottrazioni e di anidride carbonica in
eccesso dell'atmosfera pensate alla
enorme capacità di inversione del
riscaldamento globale abbiamo proprio
sotto i nostri piedi
questa questa
intelligenza e questo reticolo queste
sinapsi che Pulsano agiscono e fissano
sotto i nostri piedi
E
allora pensiamo a allontanarci un po' e
guardare tutto da un punto di vista
differente
da Torano Nuovo ci allontaniamo un po'
nello spazio e guardiamo il pianeta da
lontano pensiamo se
tutta la crosta terrestre fosse
ricoperta da suoli vivi e funzionanti
Quante norme capacità di stoccaggio
anidride carbonica avremmo
prendiamo un grosso respiro e torniamo
con i piedi per terra
perché la verità è che c'è una
grandissima parte di suoli che sono
in via di
decadenza
Purtroppo le lavorazioni profonde e
frequenti purtroppo i diserbi stanno
poco a poco di certificando i suoli
E pensate che ogni qualvolta diserviamo
stiamo uccidendo tutti i microrganismi
vivi nel suolo un suolo che non funziona
è un suono che non riesce a produrre
frutti sani
e quindi attraverso la qualità del suolo
passa la nostra salute ogni qualvolta
mangiamo qualcosa che viene da un suolo
diserbato Noi ci stiamo avvelenando
e
dall'altra parte invece vediamo che c'è
un agricoltura differente possibile in
cui l'uomo coltiva la biodiversità
l'uomo coltiva la fertilità con una
capacità di produrre dei frutti sani e
con una capacità nutritiva molto più
elevata
Questa è un'azione che richiede la
collaborazione di tutti perché non solo
gli agricoltori possono impegnarsi
Ma i consumatori devono prendere una
grossa scelta tutti noi dobbiamo
scegliere se quello che mangiamo può
venire da un'agricoltura di quel tipo
un'agricoltura di quell'altro tipo
perché il futuro dell'Agricoltura può
andare in una o nell'altra direzione
quando vi parlavo dei diserbi sappiamo
bene quanto nocivi e quanto velenosi
questi siano e quanto la salute dipende
dal non utilizzo di questi
e le arazioni sono un altro tema molto
importante perché ogni volta che
lavoriamo il suolo oltre ad accendere il
trattore inevitabilmente quindi emettere
nella anidride carbonica nell'atmosfera
Noi stiamo passando con una lama
tagliente all'interno quel reticolato
fitto e funzionale che pulsa e comunica
Beh quella Lama interrompe ogni tipo di
comunicazione
allo stesso tempo quella agglomerato di
anidride carbonica stabile e fissato nel
suolo anch'esso viene rotto e quindi
l'anidride carbonica viene riliberata
nell'atmosfera
pensate che nei momenti delle arature
delle lavorazioni dei suoli nelle zone
di agricoltura industrializzata nei mesi
in cui siara
la parte rossa è l'anidride carbonica
che aumenta e aumenta del 25% nei
momenti delle arature profonde per poi
tornare blu una volta in cui le piante
iniziano a germogliare e tornano ad
essere fotosintetiche e tornano a ri
sottrarre quella anidride carbonica in
eccesso che c'è l'atmosfera e torna ad
essere nel suolo pensate quanto sarebbe
bello se riuscissimo a vivere piuttosto
in questa condizione più a lungo
possibile
io
vivo in una famiglia e sono contornata
da colleghi che hanno sempre messo la
qualità del suolo nella parte più alta
delle loro priorità perché non c'è una
pianta sana che può nascere da un suolo
morto
e di conseguenza avere dei suoli vivi è
la priorità assoluta per coltivare dei
frutti sani io la vivo come una grossa
responsabilità
quella di dovermi occupare di un pezzo
di terra prendermene cura e allo stesso
tempo ha un enorme possibilità e
crediamo che
c'è un agricoltura sana un'agricoltura
viva possibile che passa attraverso ad
esempio ci punti
il primo quello di non utilizzare i
serbi ad oggi ci sono più di 200 studi
che provano che i diservi e glifosato
sono cancerogeni ogni volta che mangiamo
cose che sono che provengono da terreni
riservati Noi ci stiamo avvelenando e
poco a poco Ci stiamo ammalando è una
responsabilità degli agricoltori non
farne più uso è una responsabilità del
consumatore chiedere all'agricoltore che
profumo ha il suo suolo
l'altra parte è avere dei suoli coperti
ed inediti tutto l'anno non si può
migliorare la qualità di un suolo A meno
che sopra non c'è una pianta
fotosintetica tutto quello che quella
accumula grazie alla fotosintesi poco a
poco va nel terreno e nutri
microrganismi vivi nel suolo affinché
questi possano proliferare
l'altra parte è
smettere di lavorare smettere di
lavorare il suolo e
[Musica]
torniamo al calice di vino dell'inizio
Perché nessuno mai aprirebbe una
bottiglia di vino per bersela dopo un
mese
sappiamo tutti che questa si ossiderebbe
e poco a poco si rovinerebbe E allora
perché non ci disturba che un suolo
venga aperto e scoperto lasciato
all'aria allo erosione all'ossidazione
e quindi se decidiamo di non arare
dobbiamo comunque trovare un sistema per
seminare i nostri semi e far crescere le
nostre colture una delle soluzioni è la
semina su sodo che consiste nel poter
seminare intere culture senza dover
tagliare e ribaltare il suolo
e l'altra parte è quella di
cercare di aumentare la materia organica
la materia organica la parte viva del
suolo pensate che aumentare del 1%, la
materia organica vuol dire incrementare
di 10 tonnellate la quantità di anidride
carbonica stoccata nel suolo di un
ettaro
pensate che enorme potenzialità
allo stesso tempo mi sento di dire che è
molto importante pensare alla materia
organica come uno strumento
importantissimo in questo momento di
riscaldamento globale e di ritenzione
idrica molto difficile perché un grammo
di materia organica riesce a trattenere
10 volte il suo peso in acqua
questo sarebbe di grandissimo aiuto
anche nei confronti delle inondazioni e
l'ispirazione che abbiamo visto negli
ultimi mesi
per ultimo ma non per meno importante
c'è l'incremento della biodiversità ogni
agricoltore sa che la monocultura non
funziona e quindi dobbiamo impegnarci ad
avere una ricchezza quanto più numerosa
possibile di colture che abbiamo sui
nostri campi ma questa anche è qualcosa
che può interessarci tutti e tutti
quanti possiamo fare qualcosa pensiamo
Se ognuno di noi riuscì a Piantare un
albero ogni anno
pensate alle norme ricchezza che ci
ritroveremo in futuro
Questa
è una responsabilità che io vivo da
vicino e lo faccio con enorme gioia
perché so che attraverso un'agricoltura
sana passa il futuro di un pianeta e
anche la salute di un popolo e
però è una rivoluzione sana solo se
collettiva solo se tutti quanti proviamo
entrare come con un microscopio
all'interno di un suolo e capire come
questo reticolo funziona come questo
pulsa e quanta attenzione Dobbiamo
dargli
e vi lascio con un invito quello di
prestare attenzione alla bellezza di un
suolo perché attraverso di questo passa
la bellezza di un paesaggio e adesso ne
sapete anche il ruolo nel frattempo io
vi aspetterò ogni qualvolta vorrebbe
mettere il naso su un pugno di solo
profumato Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]